- May Fifth before you
watch this video. May Fifth
I'm dropping it, huge project.
Please, please pay
attention to all my socials,
all my channels May 5th.
I've got a secret project.
I'm dropping it with a complete focus
on making sure (A) that
everybody part of this community
my OG social media content
YouTube gets to really win.
Wait till you see the
way I structured this.
This isn't just the art.
There's a lot of access and community
and a lot of fucking thoughtfulness.
Months and months in the making.
May 5th be ready.
Have your metamask filled
with as much Etherium as you can afford.
We're doing it.
- Gary, Gary V showed me.
- Zellenials, it's me, Gary V.
I am ridiculously humbled
by having this quick
opportunity to say 'what's up?'.
What's good?
How are you? For those of
you that don't know me,
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm a New York Jets fan.
I'm a Jersey boy that was
born in the Soviet Union.
That is very grateful and driven
by perspective around patience,
optimism, practicality
work ethic, kindness.
And what's really exciting
for me is (A) first of
all, kudos to everybody
who's watching this to finding this place.
I love the innovation of the
internet and Facebook groups
I think has been remarkable
for many different people.
And knowing that there's a large group
of Zellenials in here who
are feeding off each other,
helping each other really
makes my heart smile.
I have very little time.
So let me just get right to the chase.
Life is about perspective
at 23, 24, 25, 26, 27
28 years old I was stocking shelves
and ringing up people
for wine purchases at,
let me, let me go.
Wine purchases at a liquor store.
Most people in their early twenties
greatest mistake is not
understanding how young they are.
As a matter of fact, as
all of you are looking
for jobs or figuring
out a post COVID world
or sad that you missed
graduation or spring break
the reality is you have a hundred years
of life in front of you.
You haven't even started.
Having it figured out by 25
27 30 is ridiculous.
The anxiety that people feel at 30.
As a matter of fact
it is literally D-Rock's
30th birthday today.
And he's never felt
younger because he's been
in a cocoon of my world for
the last half decade, right?
You've never felt younger, right?
D-Rock - You're not wrong
Gary V- And these characters
are 22, 23, 19,20.
You haven't even started.
I don't want to hear
that you can't get a job
enjoy your vacation, enjoy your vacation.
And by the way, you have no money
and you can't enjoy get six roommates.
Like you're a kid do not
listen to your parents
or society that you
have to have it figured
out it's just not true.
Most of your parents
have not had it figured
out ever let alone at 22, 23.
Take a breath, be grateful
that you're alive and are
watching this video. Gratitude
of what you have versus crying
about what you don't have.
Most of you are stressed
about getting a job
and then you're gonna have a job
in six months and you're
not going to like it.
Take a breath.
I gave up all my twenties
to build a big wine store
for my dad and mom.
I spent my twenties into my
early thirties getting underpaid
for what I was doing for their business
because it's a family business
to set them up proper.
And then
at 34 kind of started the
career that you know me for now.
Think about that.
34, 34 that's a hundred years away.
Zellenials, you are
sitting in the best spot.
You are in the most fortunate spot NFTs
social media, influencers,
Shopify, commerce
Spotify, SoundCloud,
creativity everywhere.
People needing people to
understand social everywhere.
People needing people, filming
and recording and editing
and writing everywhere.
Entrepreneurship opportunity everywhere.
And if you do everything wrong
for the next seven, eight,
nine years, everything wrong
you're still then young to go conservative
or safe or back to school or... Stop.
People's relationship
with time is their greatest vulnerability.
And my great hope is in these five minutes
I've changed the framework or
started the spark or the seed
for you to get much more
thoughtful about the reality
of you and your age and where
you are in your life cycle.
This doesn't mean be lazy
and chill on the couch.
Have ambition and conviction
but have patience and humility.
You worrying about what
everybody else thinks
of your success is your vulnerability.
Put these fingers in
your ears, live for you.
Be high risk now because
it's actually practical.
I'm so honored to be here.
I hope this brought you a second of value.
Please DM me, DM me, Garyee on Instagram
hit me up on my /Gary Facebook page.
Whatever works for you.
I'm here for you.
If I can, I get flooded,
but I still randomly do it.
I'm here.
Let me help. Hope you have a great day.
Thank you for having me really
really thank you so much for
having me and keep curious,
keep patient and keep
conviction for doing it for you.
Even though you love and
respect other people's opinions
you have to do it for you.
Thank you.
YouTube watcher, what's up?
It's Gary V first of
all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.